well the way I interpret what What chop
and I was saying I know you're an
experience
but the way I interpret what he was
saying was basically there's a
combination of Will and representation
and it's the combination that's
important so that's what I mean by when
I use the term metaphor I mean you're
putting those two things together
right so but there is something else
there is a higher form of determinacy I
call it meta causation sometimes that
actually is determining what happens
it's not just the representation it's
not just the will it's the two things
intended
brief aside for today's sponsor nordvpn
please continue watching as doing so
supports toe for me privacy is a large
deal I'm not a fan of the tech Giants or
isps having such huge amount of
information on my IP my location nordvpn
keeps my information encrypted so I
don't have to worry about the immense
data that I have that's being put out
there being sold or even known nordvpn
also has the added benefit that if
you're jaded from the US Netflix for
example then you can switch to the UK
Netflix and it's as simple as a click of
a button you know I like referencing
Dragon Ball Z and Miyazaki well no need
to travel to Japan for your favorite
anime when nordvpn brings it directly to
you they even protect your phone's
internet usage all with one click of
their software use the link nordvpn.com
theories you'll receive a sizable
discount on the two-year plan plus one
month free on top of that all links are
in the description and the comments
what's meant by the word representation
so for schopenhauer the wheel is the
Inner Essence of everything it's what
really exists he com he equates that to
Khan's numina
um the collection of pneumonomes pneumon
that forms existence that forms the
universe and the representation is just
the outside appearance of the wheel if I
can quote him
the representation is how the will
presents itself can you give me an
analogy or an example
um combustion presents itself as flames
combustion is the thing in itself an
oxidation process that releases energy
forms ions leading to a plasma and what
we call Flames is how it looks like it's
what combustion looks like so for
schopenhauer all there is is Will in
other words endogenous conscious states
that that's what he means by using the
word will he means endogenous
experiences you know in other words
experiences that are not perceptual in
nature they are endogenous they rise
from within
and representation is how those
experiences present themselves to
external observation so the world is
Will
and the world presents itself to us as
the physical world which is pure
representation and for schopenhauer
causality is a as a concept applies only
to representation so only when you're
talking about the language of
representation can you talk about
causality the will behind it as the
thing in itself precedes causality but
it is not random because it follows
certain archetypal templates and he goes
on and Compares that with Plato's ideal
forms and so on so in essence
schopenhauer I think well in spirit
schopenhauer was a determinist with the
important caveat that he was a subtle
determinist he would say and he he
wouldn't say that causality is the whole
thing he would say causality is emergent
causality is something that applies to
the language of appearances not of the
things in themselves but the things in
themselves are not purely random they
also unfolding unfold according to
certain templates so in that sense that
the spirits of determinism is preserved
in schopenhauer if not the letter
yes I would say that schopenhower was a
metaformal metadatriminist and I would
say that basically he was a semiatician
as well I would say that he had this
idea that there was something called
will from which a semiotic
representation emerged
emergencies of course a concept that
you've already mentioned so in in my
system in my system of metaphysics
Telesis is primary will his primary and
that it factorizes itself it actually
fractionates sort of or factors itself
into two sides of representation which
is the sign and the thing signified by
it okay plus something called thirdness
which of course is is uh is The
Interpreter of of the sign and all of
these things three things are combined
in the ctmu in the metaformal system by
something called triality which means
that any object can be regarded as a
relation or an operation
or a process you can take all of those
things at everywhere combine them so
that's that's that's very good yes I
think that this is something that
schopenhauer was trying to formulate but
he was he didn't have the mathematics at
the time you know he lived you know a
long time ago and they didn't have most
of these Concepts out there so he was
unable to Marshal them all and scrape
them together and build a system up
so that's what that's what I'm trying to
make up for is lost time due to
insufficient mathematical understanding
of what was going on with these Concepts
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy